oh yeah sweet oh ok so right now I'm  here is getting his ass kicked done dan  down but a little bit training older  brother it's a boom 12 whoo laughing  when he does espheni here instead I can  do it like a flying side kick to it blah  blah well I met to go that Jessica okay  Pam back kick Bennett in the roundhouse  kick is there you know what I do a check  and then do like a backache to my face  where you're like hold it yeah yeah  there you see that and that's my man  just go super saiyan yeah oh super  saiyan on my ass I don't know it's super  saiyan or whatever song let's try to  block it okay lingsha tickling me all  right we good old day now yeah right I'm  talking ronix ever